the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 video today I want
to give some of my thoughts on the game
of Thrones documentary as well as talk
about how I actually became a fan of the
show in the books and how it altima to
me creating my own channel for those of
you that don't know HBO made a
documentary about how the final season
of Game of Thrones was made they
documented the inner workings of how a
television show at this size gets
created I thought it was a fascinating
look and how much work goes into a
production of this size they were also
able to highlight all of the unsung
heroes who work behind the scenes to
help bring the show to life we were also
able to see some of our favorite
characters filmed their final scenes
this wasn't only emotional for everyone
on set but it was also very emotional
for the millions of fans at home
watching these characters who they
followed for all these years say goodbye
one last time as I was sitting there
watching this I started to feel this
overwhelming sense of nostalgia it made
me think back to the days of when I
finally became aware of Game of Thrones
and how it Altima led me to where I am
today I know many of you have wanted to
know a little bit about me so I figured
this will be a good time to tell you my
own story about how I became a fan of
Game of Thrones and how it led to me
making my own videos about this show
that I became obsessed with almost
overnight somehow Game of Thrones was on
television for a very long time before I
even knew that it existed I was actually
missing out on this amazing show for
years because I was working so much so
that I did not even notice it in fact I
never saw anyone talking about it on
Facebook and no one at my work was ever
talking about it either in order for me
to find out about this show it would
take for something to go viral for it to
even come across my radar back at that
time now you would think the red wedding
would be something big enough to get my
attention but I did not even know about
that as it was happening I honestly
don't know how I never saw anything
about it on social media back then but
obviously I eventually did see something
and boy oh boy was it a very big spoiler
if it wasn't
Jon Snow's death I might not be sitting
here talking to you today I can still
remember it like it was yesterday
one night I got on Facebook and as I was
looking at the newsfeed I see a photo of
a man dressed in all black lying dead in
the snow right above the photo was a
headline that said something along the
lines of Jon Snow died tonight on the
game of Thrones Season 5 Finale so I
must have saw this right after that
episode had ended I remember I continued
looking at the photo thinking what the
hell is Game of Thrones
who the hell is Jon Snow and why is he
dead for several days I could not get
the image out of my head all I could
think about was that guy dressed in all
black in his blood soaking into the snow
underneath to him by the end of that
week I had to find out about the show I
did wonder if there was some sort of a
connection to his name in the location
of his dead body
so obviously before I even started
watching the show I already knew that
Jon Snow would die now the good thing
about never hearing anyone talk about
the show is nothing else was spoiled for
me before I started watching I did not
know about Ned Stark dying nor did I
know anything about the red wedding the
only thing I knew was Jon Snow would
eventually die because of the photo when
I sat down to watch to the show for the
first time I told myself if I don't like
the show by the end of the second
episode I'm not watching anymore I
figured if I do not find it to be
interesting or entertaining after the
second episode then it most likely is
not a show for me now there is a reason
why I said that to myself when I read
the description of the show it said it
was a fantasy show before Game of
Thrones I was never a fan of fantasy so
when I read that I was already very
worried I was not a fan of Dungeons and
Dragons or zombies or even superhero
movies if I'm being honest I always
wanted to watch something that felt very
realistic it was always hard for me to
get invested into something that made me
drastically suspend my disbelief if it
did not feel like it could really happen
or have actual stakes or consequences
for the characters then I wasn't
interested
well Game of Thrones was actually able
to combine all of these things in a way
that did make it feel very realistic now
I have heard some fans say that the
scene that made them want to keep
watching was when Jamie through brain
out of the window for me I did not even
need to see that to want to keep
watching I was fully invested by the end
of the opening scene before the opening
credits even began as you all know the
opening scene begins at Castle black
we see three men of the Nights Watch go
out beyond the wall for some reason at
the time you don't really know why they
are heading out there but the way the
opening scene was set up you could
already feel the danger the setting the
atmosphere the black horses and the
black outfits set against the all-white
landscape made for one hell of an
opening scene my imagination was already
running wild I still had no idea what
kind of show it would be remember the
only photo I had seen thus far was the
photo of Jon Snow I had no idea about
the White Walkers or dragons or shadow
babies or anything like that I had no
idea what to expect then we see them
find all the dead bodies and even a
little girl that has been mounted on a
tree I thought what the hell is
happening out here what is out there in
those woods then we see her again and
she's no longer stuck on the tree now
her eyes are blue and these creatures
come out of the shadows to begin to
chase the men through the woods
any other time I most likely would have
shut off the TV when that happened I
would have thought here we go again
another show or movie about zombies I
can't even explain the way I felt but
there was something about the way this
opening scene was done that made me very
interested in finding out what was
happening in the woods beyond that
big-ass wall like I said I did not like
fantasy stories before this but there I
was getting fully invested into a show
because of its unexplainable fantasy
elements in the opening scene then we
meet the stark family and I mean come on
who did not love the Starks after their
first scene together since it was the
photo of Jon Snow that made me want to
watch the show I always had a close eye
on the character throughout the entire
series because I wanted to find out what
led to his death in the first episode we
find out some little details about who
he is as a character this was when I did
realize holy [ __ ] there are actually a
lot of similarities between Jon Snow and
myself now remember at this time we are
led to believe Ned Stark is John's
father but John does not carry his last
name he doesn't even have his mother's
last name although we do not know who
she is yet I related to this immediately
because I do not have my mother or
father's last name either now this might
be a little confusing but before my mom
met my dad she was married to someone
else after they got divorced my mom
continued to keep the last name of who
she was married to I don't know why but
she still carries
that last name until this day so then my
mom met my dad then she had me and my
dad has never been in my life ever since
so naturally my mom did not give me his
last name
thank God she gave me her maiden name
which means I grew up my whole life not
having my mom or dad's last name which
is exactly like John Snow then we begin
to see how lady Catelyn treats John Snow
and let's just say my stepdad back then
was the same way with me when you grow
up in that kind of environment you want
to get away as soon as you can
so what does John do almost immediately
he wants to join the Nights Watch this I
could also relate to as soon as I
graduated high school I immediately
signed up for the military I wanted to
get away from everything in hopes of
finding some sort of purpose guarding my
own realms of men you can imagine by the
end of the first episode I thought well
damn I am Jon Snow and Jon Snow is me
you can see why he became my favorite
character I know exactly how he felt and
why he wanted to join the Nights Watch
now I felt like I had an even bigger
investment into the show but I was only
scratching the surface honestly I could
not get enough of it I went through all
five seasons before that week was even
over then I did something I have never
done with any other show and in fact I
still haven't done this with any other
show as soon as I was done watching all
of the seasons for the first time I
immediately started them over again now
as you all know there is nothing like
watching a great show for the first time
but the second watch had so much of
value because I was now able to notice
things I did miss during the first watch
I watched it for the second time just as
fast as I watched it the first time now
I needed someone to talk to but still
none of my friends were talking about it
nor was anyone talking about it at work
I had all these different ideas running
around in my head keeping me up late at
night but I had no one to discuss them
with I had no idea there were thousands
and thousands of fans already discussing
things online the only social media I
was using back then was Facebook and I
never saw anyone talking about it there
I've never been a Reddit user either so
that never even crossed my mind
then the season 6 trailer came out and
that's what led me to YouTube after
watching the trailer over and over again
I was eventually recommended a video
that video was about Rhaegar Liana and
John and I had no idea anyone was making
these Theory videos online but once I
saw that I thought holy [ __ ] this is
what I need to do this is how I can talk
about this show that I love and all the
different ideas I had about where I
thought the different storylines were
heading there was only one issue I did
not know how to make videos because I
had never made a video before if you go
back and watch some of my first videos
they are really really bad I did not
know how to work a microphone I did not
know how to edit I didn't know how to do
anything like that also it's very
uncomfortable to sit alone and talk into
a microphone I really don't know why I
guess it's like a stage for a kind of
thing but it took me a very long time to
start to get comfortable recording
myself and releasing it for everyone to
listen to and criticize all that being
said I still wanted to make them anyway
because I needed to find a way to
discuss all these thoughts I had about
the show and thankfully there are
hundreds of thousands of other people
out there just like me
who want to do the same thing thanks to
the internet we were able to find each
other and create a community of our own
where we can discuss these ideas with
one another over 300 videos later and
here we are at the very end of Game of
Thrones as I was watching the
documentary on Sunday night we were
seeing everyone say goodbye to something
that has had such a big impact on their
life and I know it has certainly
affected mine
one of the biggest standouts from the
documentary has to be Andy McClay this
man has been an extra on Game of Thrones
for a very long time I actually felt
like he was a good representation of all
of us he is someone that fell in love
with a story so much that he dedicated
his own time and effort into showing
exactly how much he does care there is a
scene from the documentary where Andy
goes in to get some makeup done on his
face when he gets there the makeup
artist mentions how Andy's house was on
fire but he still showed up for work on
time almost anyone else would have not
shown up for work that day but not Andy
he mentions how this helped him escape
from his own reality of what was
happening
if that isn't dedication then I don't
know what is after hearing his story and
following him around for most of the
documentary I could only hope that he
was able to get another job on one of
the new shows that I set in the a Song
of Ice and Fire universe I'm glad that
HBO decided to make the documentary that
way they could shine a light on everyone
that assisted in making game
Thorne's become one of the most
successful shows in television history
I know many fans do not like how the
writing was done on the final season
which I do understand because there were
a lot of things that I did not like
about the season either but the
documentary mainly focused on everything
else that it takes to bring something of
this size to life I don't think anyone
can say a bad thing about the show
special effects the costumes that make
up the music and even the set designs
how about that King's Landing said they
built right on the studio lot that
looked amazing especially some of those
houses that had balconies they were so
nice up a dam I could actually live in
one of those some of the hardest scenes
to watch in this was when the actor shot
their last scenes and said goodbye some
of them have been here working with some
of the same people for over a decade we
have literally seen some of these actors
grow up right before our very own eyes a
lot of these actors were relatively
unknown at the time but thanks the game
of thrones they have now went on to
become major celebrities it would be
very hard to walk away from something
that has given you so much for so long
Game of Thrones has been their security
blanket it was something that was always
there for them no matter what other jobs
big or small were offered to them I
actually want to thank everyone who has
done some work on the show it has given
me a lot of enjoyment throughout the
years and it also led me to finding this
amazing online community of fans around
the entire globe honestly if it weren't
for Game of Thrones I don't know where I
would be right now it might sound crazy
or dramatic to say this but I can
honestly say Game of Thrones came into
my life at a time when I needed it the
most when I discovered the show I was in
a five-year relationship with my
girlfriend at the time we had actually
just got our first house together and
before we moved in we decided we would
make some renovations first
this wasn't very easy because almost the
entire inside of the house and needed to
get redone but we could not afford to
hire workers to do it therefore I had to
do most of the work myself so after I
would get home from work I would go
right through the house and start
working on it until I was ready for a
bed this was at the same time I decided
I wanted to start making videos about
Game of Thrones I was working a
nine-to-five job and remodeling our
house and trying to make videos whenever
I could find the time in those early
days most of the videos were actually
getting made when I was at work
during my lunch break or whenever I had
some downtime well right around the same
time the house was done and everything
was getting set up inside guess what
happened that five year relationship
came to an end all that work and money
that went into the house was for nothing
so you can only imagine what kind of
mental state I was in but I never said
anything at the time because I wasn't
looking for sympathy or some one
shoulder to cry on or anything like that
now although I still had my job I was
now completely broke from trying to get
the house remodeled and furnished so I
had to actually move back into my mom's
house until I could get back on my feet
this was before season seven came out so
I wasn't making any money on YouTube
thanks to my mom letting me move back in
I was able to work my ass off and save
money until I could get back on my feet
which I eventually did now whenever I
wasn't working Game of Thrones and the
community was the only other thing I had
whenever I needed to escape from my own
reality one of you were always there to
talk to and I cannot thank you all
enough
and when I say Game of Thrones and the
community was there when I needed it the
most I really mean it
anyone who has ever supported me or
their Channel I have to thank you from
the bottom of my heart it has been one
hell of a ride to say the least I do
have some other videos I will be
releasing this week I hope to see you
all come back for those ones as well
thank you for watching this one have a
great day everyone
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you